A violent attack
on a Democratic congressman's office.
Representative
Gerry Connolly says a man wielding
a metal baseball bat injured two staffers
at his Virginia office
just outside of Washington, D.C..
Jessica Schneider
is on the scene for us right now.
So what are authorities saying, Jessica?
Well, right now, Wolf, they're not saying
what exactly the motivation here was,
but sources are telling our John Miller
that this suspect
was, in fact, known
to Congressman Connolly's officers.
So all of this unfolded
just before 11:00 this morning
at the district office
here in Fairfax, Virginia.
We're about 20 miles outside Washington.
Police have identified the suspect
as 49 year old Xuan Car Tran Pham.
They say that he entered this office here
with a metal bat
and then attacked two staffers.
One was a senior staffer
who was struck in the head.
The other was actually an intern.
It was her first day on the job.
Now, our Capitol Hill team
actually talked to Congressman
Connolly on the phone earlier today.
He described it
as a really out of control attack.
He said that this attacker went inside,
smashed some of the glass
in a conference room,
also broke several computers
And here's
the Fairfax City police sergeant.
Here's what she had to say.
You could absolutely
tell that the people inside were scared.
They were hiding.
I mean, someone
swinging a bat around.
I would be scared as well.
Capitol Police.
And tonight,
we're actually
learning our team on the ground
has talked
with the father of this suspect.
He says that he suffers from
schizophrenia,
has not taken his medication
in three months.
And court records reveal
that this same suspect actually
was charged
with assaulting a police officer
several years ago.
The charges,
though, were ultimately dropped.
Now, Congressman Connolly,
he was actually not
at this district office.
He was nearby
at a food pantry, ribbon cutting.
But he did release a statement
about this.
He said this.
He said the thought that someone
would take advantage of my staff's
accessibility to commit
an act of violence
is unconscionable and devastating.
Now, the two people who were attacked,
they were taken to the hospital,
non-life-threatening injuries.
But, Wolf,
this is really coming on the heels
of of many threats
to members of Congress,
as well as their staff.
In fact, the U.S.
Capitol Police
chief, Tom
Major, testified in a hearing
just last month
saying that threats have gone up
400% in the past six years.
What's so, so disturbing?
Jessica Schneider, thank you very much.
She's on the scene for us.
Let's discuss
what's going on with Representative
Veronica Escobar, a Democrat of Texas,
a member of Congress.
Congresswoman, thanks so much
for joining us.
What's your reaction to this attack?
And staffers in Congressman
Gerry Connolly's office,
it comes amid,
as you heard,
a wave of truly unprecedented
violence, threats
and attacks against U.S. lawmakers.
Well, Wolf,
my heart goes out to the staff members.
You know,
these are public servants
who go to work every day
and they are there to help
serve constituents.
And I can't help
but think of my own staff
and everything
that they've had to go through,
you know, whether it is
horrible harassing calls or awful
hateful email to the threat of attack.
And we know those of us in Congress,
especially those of us
who survived January 6th
and we were here,
just how terrifying
all of those attacks are,
we have to be very vigilant
and apparently our staff
also has to be very vigilant.
It should not be this way.
Have you increased security
for your staff at your offices?
Yes.
Over the years,
I have increased security
for my staff in the district office,
also around my home, frankly.
But it's it is still terrifying.
We have to be accessible
to our constituents.
We have to interact with them.
And every time that we do,
it comes with some risk.
I want to get your thoughts.
Congresswoman, I know
the special counsel, John Durham's report
that was released earlier today.
Do you support the judiciary chairman Jim
Jordan's call
to have to have Durham testify
before Congress?
I know you're a member
of the Judiciary Committee.
What do you think?
I am a member of the House Judiciary
Committee and Chairman Jordan.
Unfortunately, instead of
using the committee
as a vehicle
for getting real work
done for the American people,
in solving the many challenges
that we face in our country.
He has used it as an opportunity
for performance,
and I have not yet
read the Durham report, but I have
definitely had an opportunity
to look through some of it.
I've heard reports about it.
We've spent
an awful lot of money
as an American government
on a report that essentially proves
no wrongdoing.
But the fact that that Chairman
Jordan wants to just continue this shows
their their disinterest
in really the work of governing.
I want to quickly turn
to the issue of the southern border.
You represent El Paso in Texas
after title 42.
How concerned are you, Congresswoman,
that the situation there will devolve
as processing times
take longer
and longer and facilities fill up?
Wolf, I can share with you
that from the inception of Title
42, I and other Democrats
essentially called out
the fact that Title 42
was only making things worse.
It created a revolving door.
It made it
so that migrants were attempting
entry multiple times.
It placed a tremendous amount of stress
on communities like my own,
my community of El Paso, Texas,
has been the site of the
highest numbers of encounters
both in 20, 22.
And I believe the same will hold
true for 20, 23.
So title 42
should have gone away a long time ago.
The administration tried
but was sued by red states
like my own in Texas.
And so finally, it's gone.
We can now create, I think, some sort of
semblance of normalcy,
but we can never predict the future.
We don't know what's around
the next corner
in terms of the challenges
that we face,
in terms
of what will be driving
vulnerable populations
from their homeland.
That's why it is so important,
in fact,
more important than ever
for Congress to take this moment.
And finally, in a bipartisan way, act
on reforming outdated processes
and outdated immigration laws.
And so see if that happens.
Representative Veronica Escobar,
thanks so much for joining us. Thank you.